ja alle diejenigen von euch schon mal
die tosende brandung des meeres mehr in
live betrachtet haben die kölner an
welche unendliche kraft hinter den
wellen stellt liegt doch nahe dass man
den ozean als einen gigantischen
stromlieferanten nutzen könnte gerade
läuft der härtetest für ein neues
wellenkraftwerk vor schottland und das
ist echt nicht ohne wie genau können
allein die wellenbewegungen des meeres
zur energiegewinnung dienen und was sind
die herausforderungen herzlich
willkommen bei klick zum science fiction
ihr habt euch bei whatsapp genau dieses
thema gewünscht und hier ist es das was
da im nordatlantik schwimmt sieht nur
auf den ersten blick aus wie eine
bohrinsel
tatsächlich aber handelt es sich um
einen prototypen eines neuen
wellenkraftwerk es anders als bei den
sogenannten gezeitenkraftwerken wird
hierbei nicht die energie des wassers
bei flut und ebbe genutzt also der
unterschied zwischen den beiden niveaus
um turbinen anzutreiben stattdessen soll
der wellengang an sich zur
energiegewinnung genutzt werden diese
wasser bewegung ist in einigen
meeresgebieten tatsächlich so hoch dass
das funktionieren kann physikalisch
gesehen wird die energie in den wellen
in form potenzieller lager energie und
in form von bewegungsenergie der wasser
partikel gespeichert schätzung zufolge
kann die energiedichte bis zu 1000
kilowatt pro meter seitenlänge einer
welle erreichen wobei tiefere gewässer
eine höhere energiedichte aufweisen als
flache es gibt studien nach denen das
physikalische potenzial der
wellenenergie weltweit auf bis zu zehn
terawatt geschätzt wird das ist echt
nicht ohne
der name des neuen wellen kraftwerks vor
den schottischen orkney islands der
laute c3 wellenenergie konverter und er
soll deutlich effektiver sein als alles
was vor ihm die meeresenergie in strom
umwandeln konnte konkret besteht der
wellenenergie converter aus einer
schwimmenden boje die von den wellen im
wasser hoch und runter schaubild um
genau diese auf und abbewegung wird dann
von einer gezähmten schiene und eine art
getriebe in eine drehbewegung
umgewandelt und damit wird der generator
dann
endlich eingetrieben nach angaben des
internationalen forschungsteams waren
die tests im labor mehr als erfolgreich
der neue prototyp kann demnach fünfmal
mehr energie pro tonne erzeugen als
andere wellenkraft systeme das gelingt
wohl vor allem durch ein 8 teiliges
kaskaden getriebe dass die kraft der
wellen bewegung effektiv und gleichmäßig
auf den generator überträgt zudem sorgen
dämpfer dafür dass das system nicht
überlastet wird denn die kraft der
wellen ist nicht zu unterschätzen dazu
einer der beteiligten forscher stephan
björklund diese flexiblen einsätze sind
entscheiden denn sie ermöglichen die
gleichmäßige verteilung der last und
schützen das getriebe gegen schocks doch
die dämpfer sorgen auch dafür dass das
system setzt bei extremem wellengang
effizient läuft und die wellenbewegungen
in eine schnelle drehung der zahnräder
umgewandelt werden kann und die praxis
bedingungen sind wirklich hart für den
neuen wellenkraft generator die region
von den orkney islands die ist nicht
ohne der wellengang ist extrem hoch und
die gezeiten sehr stark zudem befindet
sich vor ort ein schwimmendes stromnetz
zu versuchszwecken genau deswegen haben
wir schon einige forschungsteams ihre
wellenkraftwerke in der praxis getestet
werden durch die anbindung an das
stromnetz können die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
herausfinden ob die boje funktioniert
kann sie also tatsächlich elektrischen
strom mit einer stabilen frequenz und
spannung erzeugen falls der konverter
diesem test besteht wird das
forschungsteam dieses system vergrößern
und es dann noch einmal langfristig
testen doch solch eine boje ist nur
eines der zahlreichen konzepte zur
nutzung von wellen energie
zudem gibt es auch speicherbecken mit
einer verengten zufluss rinne die sorgt
dafür dass die wellen an höhe gewinnen
und oberhalb des meeresspiegels in das
becken treten über eine turbine wird es
ins meer zurück geleitet und die energie
kann genutzt werden außerdem gibt es
auch anlagen mit einer oszillierende
wassersäule am meeresgrund befindet sich
eine kamera
der steigende wasserspiegel lässt die
darüberliegende luftsäule durch eine
turbine strömen die immer in dieselbe
drehrichtung beschleunigt wird egal wie
die strömungsrichtung der luft ist
optimale standorte dafür sind
beispielsweise die küsten spaniens
irlands oder norwegens und er könnte es
schon vorstellen es gibt einige vorteile
solcher konzepte es wird kein wasser
verbraucht und es gibt keinerlei abfälle
zudem wird auf die natur und umwelt
nicht sehr stark beeinflusst doch wie
bei vielen anderen arten der
erneuerbaren energien gibt es keine
regelmäßigkeit bei der stromerzeugung
gleich ist diese unregelmäßigkeit nicht
ganz so schlimm wie bei windkraftwerken
denn das mehr bewegt sich immer aber die
wellen stärken die es eben immer
unterschiedlich und nimmt keine
rücksicht darauf ob gerade viel strom im
netz benötigt wird oder nicht es werden
also auch hier puffer wie batterie
farben gebraucht zudem sind auch die
kosten für die investitionen in
wellenkraftwerke noch vergleichsweise
hoch ja mal sehen ob sich diese technik
durchsetzen kann wenn ihr keine videos
dazu und zu allen anderen themen
verpassen wollt dann endet mich bei
whatsapp dann umgeht denn die kaputte
abo box hier auf youtube und verpasst
kam video
denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir
immer vom neuesten video und zwar vorab
täglich vor allen anderen und das
garantiert einfach hier draufklicken und
am besten auch meinen schwesterkanal
klicks um social media abonnieren
was geht hier da gibt es das neueste aus
der social media welt einfach
draufklicken aber nicht die genau die
glocke vergessen und hier geht es weiter
mit dafür auch draufklicken die lüge der
energiewende bis dann bleibt dran